growing up in southern idaho one of my
favorite places to visit was swan falls
a gorgeous canyon formed by the snake
river
all throughout my childhood i remember
scrambling over the boulders down in
this canyon and playing in the cool
water at the edge of the river over
thousands and thousands of years water
slowly eroded away rock and sediment
water made this canyon
and water forms many landscapes
including valleys ravines cliffs
coastlines
all of these were largely shaped and
affected by water
and given that water covers most of the
earth or over 70 percent of it it's no
surprise that water also shapes the
earth
water is a powerful force it can
literally wash away soil and carve away
rock bit by bit which scientists
describe through two separate processes
when water breaks rocks apart it's
called weathering
and when water carries away surface soil
sediments and that broken down rock it's
called erosion
erosion by water starts with rain
during a rain storm the impact of rain
drops is actually powerful enough to
dislodge soil particles and damage soil
structure
this is called mechanical weathering
as rain water starts to accumulate it
can erode a landscape by moving soil and
rock particles called sediment away from
their original location
and as water flows down the slope of
hills and mountains it transports
sediment along with it
eventually water gathers into small
streams and then rivers
carrying more and more sediment in fact
through erosion water carries away
billions of tons of sediment to the
oceans every year
plant roots and vegetation can hold soil
in place and prevent or slow soil
erosion
but if soil has nothing to hold it down
water can erode away soil very quickly
as the volume of water increases so does
its power of erosion
in turn a large river can erode more
soil and rock quicker than a small river
can
the speed of the water flow also affects
its erosional power
simply put faster moving water can carry
more sediment
this relationship is one reason why fast
moving water causes more erosion than
the same volume of slow moving water
a great example of water erosion in
relation to speed is that of meandering
rivers and oxbow lakes you know the
weird horseshoe looking lake in this
image
let's take a look at how these oxbow
lakes form
the current of the water is fastest on
the outside of the bend
in turn these are the areas where water
tends to erode away the river bank
conversely the current of the water is
slowest on the inside of a bend
here the water slows down so much that
some of the sediment that is being
carried is dropped or deposited
this is called sedimentation
over time through erosion and deposition
an oxbow lake will form which is
eventually cut off from the river
chemical weathering is another way that
water can break rocks such as when acids
in water dissolve certain types of rocks
and minerals
over time flowing water can dissolve the
minerals and rocks on or under the
surface
this chemical weathering can cause
sinkholes caves and cliffs to form
certain rocks like limestone are
especially vulnerable to erosion in
particular limestone easily erodes due
to carbonic acid and rainwater which
forms when carbon dioxide or co2 from
the atmosphere dissolves in water in
turn limestone erosion can produce
intricate cave systems
along beaches in the ocean front coastal
erosion breaks up and wears away rock as
waves sweep in over and over they cause
rock to weather away and break off
going back to the snake river and swan
falls i can see examples of weathering
and erosion all around me
i look to the cliffs which have been
slowly carved away by the snake river
over time to reveal this amazing valley
which was formed by weathering and water
erosion
water erosion is incredibly powerful and
although it can be destructive by
removing soil and rock over thousands
and thousands of years
water erosion is also responsible for
creating the beautiful and spectacular
landscapes that we enjoy today